the audio of Trump's conversation in the
documents case is actually much much
worse than the transcription that the
doj used to indict him as you might
recall the doj's indictment had a
transcript of conversation between Trump
and a staffer in which he said Trump see
as president I could have Declassified
it staffer yeah laughter Trump now I
can't you know but this is still a
secret now that was already bad enough
but the thing is the audio has now been
released and it's actually much worse
listen to what Trump actually says
president I could have did less yeah no
I can't you know but this is yes
yeah when Trump says but this is still
classified referring to the document
that he has in his hand well that is an
admission that he didn't declassify it
and knows that he is currently in
possession of classified material and
he's basically dead to rights on these
charges all sorts of stuff pages long
boy I hope he has a good lawyer and if
you need a great lawyer let my firm the
eagle team take care of it the link is
in the comments